[Music]
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
welcome to the bonus show um i
really don't know how i feel about this
uh first story
because um i'm starting to wonder what
on earth nancy pelosi is thinking
nancy pelosi was interviewed on sunday
morning by george stephanopoulos on abc
and when asked about the possibility of
impeaching donald trump again
depending on what happens with the
supreme court and ruth bader ginsburg c
she said well you know we're not going
to rule anything out we have options
and we have arrows in our quiver was the
metaphor or analogy that she
used and there's this sort of vague idea
that if indeed donald trump can be
prevented
from uh replacing ruth bader ginsburg
before november 3rd
which is certainly fees i mean aside
from whether they have the votes it's
not crazy to think that that this might
not be enough time to get
ruth bader ginsburg replaced by november
3rd if joe biden were to win
there really wouldn't be anything
stopping trump from replacing ruth bader
ginsburg during the lame duck period
and the idea of what if they impeach
trump again has brought up
what has been brought up and nancy
pelosi didn't rule it out
my question pat is one
what would they impeach trump for and
number two
would that even prevent him from
replacing ruth bader ginsburg
i think the strategy could work because
impeachment has to take priority in the
senate over
confirmation of judges so the tactic
could work
they could pick many different things to
impeach trump over
the problem is if you do that before the
election it's going to look
like it's going to be transparent it's
going to be obvious what the democrats
are going
are doing it's going to look just like a
hit job yeah you also don't have to
impeach trump you can also impeach
william barr
there's plenty of things you can impeach
him over and maybe that would be less
divisive maybe people wouldn't see that
as much of a voting issue
uh but like it certainly changes the
whole
scale and scope of this election like it
changes what the stories are going to be
for the next six weeks or so
and that's probably not good for
democrats because we really were
winning the messaging war when it comes
to the coronavirus the economy
uh trump's readiness to lead all these
different things if you
now have to focus on the next supreme
court justice and you know consider
impeaching trump over something that
seems bogus or william barr over
something that seems bogus
i don't think that's going to be good
for uh democrats politically but then
again
having uh ruth bader ginsburg replaced
with the conservative justice also isn't
good for democrats either
so so literally the idea is just to tie
up the senate with an impeachment trial
that that's all that it is
that's exactly right yeah and uh you
know maybe they would be able to do it
we'll have to just wait and see i i my
immediate reaction is that this is not a
particularly good idea
i mean listen this is i i on on during
my commentary today on the regular show
about how
it's not clear that democrats have the
ability to stop trump from replacing rbg
i said we have to learn from this
and what unfortunately the lesson is it
was really stupid
for anyone to think in 2016 that it
didn't make a difference whether hillary
clinton or donald trump were elected
like
that's really the lesson and it's not
now that i want to punish anyone with
the lesson
it's just that's the lesson that's the
reality hopefully we all learned it and
i don't know that
another impeachment really does anything
about what the real lesson here is and
maybe they would just find a way to
confirm the justice anyway
they would be able to exonerate trump or
bar from the impeachment and then
quickly move on to confirm the justice
so yeah that may not even end up working
and of course we do have to
learn from the lessons of history uh
trump should not have been elected
president 2016 and you know if you had
more people on the left who are just
willing to vote for hillary suck it up
and vote for hillary we wouldn't be in
this situation where he's
very likely to get three justices
confirmed i also do think though we have
to fight back
and um you know if that means impeaching
in in the
last days of uh trump's presidency like
i think we should have that on the table
but i think more realistically
uh it would be good to start thinking
about packing the court assuming
democrats win the presidency and the
senate which are big assumptions like
this because only if we get power back
uh correct me if i'm wrong pat but if
biden wins but democrats don't take the
senate
biden can unilaterally expand the number
of justices
but then you would imagine republicans
if they control the senate wouldn't
confirm a single one of them right
well i don't think it would be able to
add seats to the
supreme court without having a senate
majority oh you even need the senate for
that okay all right so
basically you need the senate majority
regardless yeah and i just think you
have to fight because
right now there's a five to four
conservative majority on the court i
mean if you get this next justice
approved
it becomes six to three and it doesn't
matter what we want to do as democrats
it doesn't matter if biden takes office
and he has the house and he has the
senate yeah you know if the supreme
court is going to
overturn the affordable care act and
everything that biden wants to do in his
administration it's just going to be
pointless we're just going to be
spending
a whole bunch of time wasting a bunch of
time and so i think that's why the first
agenda item has to be adding to
supreme court justices assuming you have
the power the problem is i don't know if
that's the best thing to uh
to to do to reach out to vote new voters
like i don't know if people are
by and large in favor of packing the
court right and they probably don't even
understand the intricacies of like oh
well republicans obstructed merrick
garland and four years ago so
now they're being hypocrites like i
don't know i don't even know if they
like piece all that stuff together
well there's a bigger question actually
the other thing i've been reading is
that
there are articles saying this entire
supreme court thing
doesn't make a difference to the average
american that if you spend time on
twitter or reddit
following people and subreddits that
talk about politics
the supreme court thing seems huge the
the argument that some are making though
is this is really not a huge deal and
that so
the death of ruth bader ginsburg is not
going to be a big factor in the election
and that someone packing the courts
wouldn't really be a big factor
the counterpoint is 100 million dollars
in donations in the 40 hours following
ruth bader ginsburg's death
seems to me like it is registering with
people
yeah and you have organizations like the
lincoln project who are
uh anti-trump republicans and they seem
to be on our side when it came to the
2020 election until now now everything's
different you know like we're not
hearing from them talking about how
we need to wait until the next president
has decided before we put up a surprise
oh is that right i haven't seen anything
from them yeah that's interesting
they're republicans at the end of the
day you know they want a conservative
court they want trump to lose but they
also want him to get his justice through
before he does lose
right all right let's move on to
discussing
the stimulus checks no not the second
stimulus i'm still
talking about the by the way the second
stimulus that hasn't happened
i'm still talking about the first
stimulus nearly nine
million americans still
in october in almost october have not
received
their 1200 stimulus check and apparently
now there is a final date being placed
on this
those nine million americans if they
want their money
have until october 15th to register
their information
or potentially will forego the 1200
it's not exactly 9 million it's 8.7
million
it's been uh months has it been i guess
it's now been uh almost
it's been six months or five six months
um
who still have not gotten the money and
uh another 1.1 million have been
underpaid
including related to dependents remember
there were 500
available for each dependent under 17
years old
they have until september 30th to file
it is stunning to me pat that the
conversation of a second stimulus
has almost completely disappeared when
trump is asked about it he'll say
sure i'm for money but you know nancy
and chuck
won't do anything or whatever you know
just blaming it on nancy pelosi and
chuck schumer
democrats don't even control the senate
um and we are still talking about people
who haven't gotten their first 1200
it's been six months of a pandemic now
well i do blame
mitch mcconnell more so than trump over
the failure to pass a second stimulus
because
it's pretty clear that trump wants to do
it especially the direct payments like
he wants to send out another check with
his name on it yeah so i don't blame
trump so much and of course house
democrats want to do it too it's really
the
republicans in the senate who are all of
a sudden so incredibly concerned about
the national debt again
and we're probably going to continue
hearing that uh fear-mongering if
biden gets elected yeah i mean we should
definitely have a second stimulus that
was supposed to be delivered to us
a couple months ago right and we're just
probably not going to get it certainly
not before the election
and when you talk about all these people
who haven't even gotten the first
payment unfortunately those are the
people who probably need it the most
you think you know it's people who are
low-income earners maybe people who
don't file taxes or they don't receive
federal payments
so yeah it's probably people who are in
a very vulnerable position they may not
even know that that money is out there
for them and
you know they only have a couple more
weeks to claim it and probably there's
going to be millions of people who don't
unfortunately
it is uh it is stunning how it's not
just
the coronavirus response that's been bad
compared to other countries
the economic support has also fallen
short i mean listen i understand that
there are poor countries that can't do
as much as the united states has done
the 1200
and the enhanced unemployment i get that
but we don't typically compare ourselves
to those countries when we evaluate what
kind of a job we're doing on any
particular issue
the countries we do compare ourselves to
many have done
significantly more from the standpoint
of protections for tenants and
homeowners when it comes to replacing
paychecks when it comes to replacing
business revenue so businesses don't
have to close
why is it that we're failing every every
six ways to sunday i think the phrases
right but if the stock market needs a
bailout then they get it they just got
four trillion dollars right away at the
beginning of this thing no questions
asked
the public though they actually have to
fight tooth and nail to get any sort of
support
and you know it's not easy to uh be in
favor
of more uh stimulus if you're on the
right because they're trying to pretend
as if the economy's back already like
the stock market is back up
and uh trump is creating tens of
millions of jobs now of course
leaving out the fact that we lost 40
million dollars uh 40 million jobs at
the start of all of this
right and so they're just just they're
just trying to say that the economy's
back so there's no point of even having
another stimulus payment it's all
tragic and predictable we've been we've
nothing has happened we we said they
would claim that the job growth numbers
are amazing
we said that republicans were unlikely
to to push more money forward it's all
and
we weren't the only ones saying it to be
clear it's not like a pat ourselves on
the back moment it's just
it was so abundantly clear that this is
the way it was all going to go
uh the trump administration has named
three cities that now are at risk of
losing federal funding
because the white house has designated
them anarchist
cities sometimes trump pronounces it
anarchists
during his uh presentations we say the
word anarchists and the
three cities are new york city portland
and seattle
and trump's justice department says
these three cities have not dealt with
the crime
surrounding protests over the summer
they are being now designated as
anarchist
cities and as such we may withhold
federal tax dollars to those cities
and um the if you look at the list of
criteria it's all pretty whacked like
for example
they they the justice department says
these cities have
blocked police forces from intervening
to restore
order and some have
proposed defunding the police or
disempowering police or
they've rejected federal troops coming
in
and blah blah blah this is becoming an
act you know we talk about oh
trump kept us out of wars the war seems
to be a domestic one between
trump's federal law enforcement and
state and city rights and law
enforcement yeah and when you hear
trump talk about war or the military he
quickly transitions into talking about
crime in cities as if those are the same
things so i think
even he sees that we have this like war
on the home front
yeah but it's just pretty silly though
like the federal government is calling
these cities anarchist
jurisdictions even though they do have
governments like they still have their
local government in the state government
and of course the federal government
uh which they're in charge of so it's
just it's just stupid like political
gesturing i think and i've seen like
pictures come out uh from new york city
over the past couple of days yeah
like these nice clean streets of
manhattan with very few people walking
down them because of the pandemic maybe
a couple people
in the shot wearing masks but you see
these beautiful flowers just looks like
a nice day in manhattan
and uh you see under it the caption like
this is an anarchist city so it's just
stupid fear-mongering and it's it's
meant to appeal to people who don't even
know what those cities are like
now do you think that this makes a
difference to anybody because okay
even if people aren't paying attention
to justice department designations of
cities as anarchist cities at every
rally this week
trump has shown up and talked about it
and the crowd claps even though again
it's not completely clear that the crowd
even knows what trump is talking about
like does this really matter to the
average voter
i feel like it's the type of thing that
probably should make an impact because
you have the justice department
uh which is supposed to you know have a
lot of integrity and people are supposed
to think highly of it saying that
we have anarchist cities so like that
alone should carry a lot of weight
but like everything else it's become so
politicized especially under trump that
i don't think people take it seriously i
mean again i'm trying to imagine
the undecided voter we talked yesterday
on the regular show about who are the
undecided voters or
rather no i researched yesterday for the
friday show
who are undecided voters and they tend
to be younger they tend to be center to
center right
they tend to not be paying attention to
politics are you going to be moved to
vote for trump
because he designated three cities as
anarchist cities i
i just have a hard time imagining that
maybe they would be swayed on the crime
issue in general like if they're able to
buy into the right wing talking points
yeah and you know
labeling these cities anarchist cities
as part of that
soup uh but i don't think like on that
alone people are going to make up their
minds but no you know when you talk
about people who are undecided at this
point
i don't i don't know like what are they
even voting on like what is going to be
the issue that drives them because
they're undecided to begin with
so it's like hard to put yourself in
their heads to begin with what i've been
looking at for this friday show segment
is that those voters ultimately tend to
either vote on
their general impression of how the
economy is doing and their general
impression may not be accurate
but their general impression of how the
economy is doing and what is described
as a
gut feeling so it doesn't seem like with
that in mind
a justice department declaration about
anarchist cities is going to be what
changes their mind
yeah that kind of goes back to that
conversation about how this election
will be decided by meta issues that's
what alan lichtman talks about right how
it's really going to come down to the
coronavirus and the economy and yeah
there's a lot of like gut feeling that's
wrapped up in both of those things
um so yeah i do still think that the
fundamentals of this
uh race are going to be about those two
issues
now you have the supreme court situation
too maybe that's going to play a bit of
a factor but i think it's ultimately
going to be mainly coronavirus and the
economy
we will be here with you including this
coming tuesday night september 29th
the first debate assuming it doesn't get
cancelled between donald trump and
joseph r biden jr
we will be starting our coverage at 8 30
p.m on the east
5 30 p.m in the west and it is going to
be
a great coming together hopefully of our
audience and we will have so much to
discuss
but before then we'll have new shows and
bonus shows all of this week
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]